[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Merhabalar bazı kadım sözler vardır yü
yıl hatta bin yıllardan aktarılarak Bize
gelen yaşadıkça hayatta karşılığı
olduğunu düşündüklerim biri de her şerde
vardır bir hayır gençken bu tür genel
geçer sözlerden hiç hoşl
bunların insanları pasifliği ittiğini
sonunda da teslimiyete ittiğini
düşünürdüm ama aslında öyle değil
yaşadıkça da bu Kadim
sözlerin Aslında etkili bir
başkaldırış dönüştürücülü gizli
olabildiğini gördüm Buna rağmen bu Kadim
sözlerin her zaman geçerli
olmayabileceğini de mesela ölümcül
felaketlerde ya da savaşlarda onca insan
giderken ağaçların dimdik durmasına
rağmen insan hayvanlar yıkıntılarının
altında kalırken nasıl bir hayır
olabilirdi ki benzer şekilde
canlılar aynı ırk ve dinden insanlar
birbirlerini öldürürken nasıl bir hayır
bekleyebilir di ki insan takvimler
2020'nin ilk aylarını gösterdiğinde
Çin'de İtalya'da covid vakalarını haber
bültenleri giderek daha fazla yer
veriyordu Böyle bir dönemde yepyeni bir
döneme girerken
dünya saatlerin durduğu yeni bir döneme
girmek üzereydi zaten çevre felaketleri
le alarm veren yerkürenin ve tükenen
diğer canlıların sesini dinlemeyen
İnsanoğlu
2020-2022 döneminde önce yüksekten onca
yüksekten bakan tavrına rağmen susup iç
muhasebesini yapmak zorunda kaldı kaldı
ve gördü ki insanoğlunun birkaç ayda
bile tekrar
Eee kirliliğinin olmadığı bir dünyada
dünya birkaç ayda bile kendine
gelebilmiş birbiriyle husumet içindeki
ülkeler hastalığa şifa olmak için ortak
mücadelede birleşti rutinlerin
kıskacından çıkıp sabah uyandığında
penceresindeki kediyi köpeği
sardunya'nın elini sıkamadığımız
yılı Mart ayında ülkemizde de covid-19
vakalarının görüldüğü zaman Eee günlük
hareketi 30.000'e yakın insan trafiğinin
olduğu 3000 kişinin çalıştığı bir ağır
sanayi şirketinin
ceo'suyla ve depresif ortama rağmen
kendimizi kaptırmadan hayata yeniden
bağlanarak paydaşlarımızın en zor
zamanlarında yanlarında olmuş satışımız
% üzerinde arttırmış be kıtada binden
fazla satış noktasına ulaşabilmiş
ihracat pazarımız 90 ülkenin üzerine
çıkarmıştık Harekete Geçmek hayal
kırıklığı anında en iyi savunma
mekanizmanın olabilir burada bilinçsizce
yapılan harekette bereket var gibi
girişimleri kastetmiyorum Tabii ki bilgi
ve tecrübeyle stratejik hareket edebilen
akılcıl bir bilinç ve Lider dahilinde
artan karşılıklı etkileşim tüketici ya
da herhangi bir karar vericinin aynı
anda çok daha fazla değişkeni bir arada
değerlendirmesini gerektiriyor Artık iş
modelleri de hayatta çok daha fazla
sofistike aynı anda çok farklı
disiplinleri birbirinden farklı
parametreleri bir arada düşünebilmenin
gerekiyor Bu eğilim pandemi öncesinde
Zaten güçlüydü pandemi farklı ülkeleri
ortak Hayati kaygılarla birleştirirken
çözüm için Kolektif düşünebilmenin
önemini de
arttırdı resimde gördüğünüz Eee ayakta
sizi selamlayan benim halam
görülebiliyor mu bilmiyorum namı diyer
didoş 2021 Mart
ayında Göreve yeni başladığımda genel
müdür olarak halam halam 91 yaşında
çiçeği burnunda bir şampiyondu
Tahsildaroğlu da tebriğe gelen bir
kişiden aldığım covid-19
virüsü tedbirli olmamıza rağmen halama
geçtiği için 10 gün sonra kaybettiğimiz
didoş o sırada aynı sebepten hastanede
hayat mücadelesi veren eşim ve bana
haber veremedikleri için Sessiz sedasız
defnedilen
didoş Hayat bazen kontrolünüzde
gelişmiyor bizzat aldığım tedbirlerle
30.000 kişiye tehlike yaşatmadan
geçirdiğim pandemi bir yıl sonra tarihte
hayatımı alt üst etmişti çok sınandım
hastanede eşimin sağlığına ilişkin
kaygım ardından taburcu edilmeden önce
sakinleştiriciler eşliğinde yarı anne
gibi gördüğüm Dido şumun ölüm haberini
aldığımda o sırada kalkmak
zorundaydım hastalığın yaptığı tahribat
sayesinde kan dolaşım sistemim kalbim
karaciğerim başta olmak üzere tüm
organlarım zaten çok yorgundu her şeye
rağmen ayağa kalkmak gerekiyordu aa
kalmam sadece kendim için değil hala
hayat mücadelesi veren eşim ve Kendi
Ayakları üzerinde durmaya çalışan
Çocuklarım beni seven herkes için
gerekliydi tüm acıma rağmen ayağa
kalktım 2021 yılında tahsildar oğlunda
tekrar işe döndüğümde tüketicinin
tercihlerinde hala pandem minin etkisi
sürüyordu hijyen ve sağlık birin
derecede önemliydi her şeyin çok hızlı
değiştiği bir
dünyada bugünün tüketicisi vz
kuşağı anlaşılmak istiyor Tüketiciyi ve
onun içinde bulunduğu dinamikleri
anlayabilmeniz için ürettiğiniz malın ve
teknik Eee bilgilerinin yanı sıra onun e
tüketicinin de dilinden anlayabilmeniz
ihtiyaçlarını bilebil meniz çok önemli
Dolayısıyla satab diğin ii üretmeniz
gerekiyor ürettiğiniz satmak
değil başarıyı yakalayabilen için ii
mühendis ler kadar çok sayıda e bileşeni
parametreyi değerlendirebilecek
finansçılar da iyi bir veri analitiği iş
birimleri arasındaki koordinasyona da
çok ihtiyacınız var keza pazarlama aynı
şekilde Eee tüketicilerin nabzını çok
iyi Tutabilecek olan pazarlamacılara da
2008-2009 krizini hatırlayalım
küresel kriz dönemleri aslında Eee canlı
bir laboratuvar ortamı da sunar Nitekim
o tarihlerde mckinzie gibi dünya çapında
danışmanlık kuruluşlarının yapmış olduğu
çalışmalarda görüldü ki kadınların
yönettiği şirketlerin risk yönetimleri
ve kriz yönetimleri diğerlerinden açık
ara
başarılıydı benzer bir görünümü
202021 pandemi
döneminde Almanya ve Yeni Zelanda'ya
yöneten kadın liderler ve
kriz ekonomik kriz döneminde Eee FED
eski başkanı bayan yalan'ın başarılı
yönetiminde de
görebiliriz bu performansı çok büyük
ölçüde Aslında kadınların çok farklı
açılardan ve daha çok Kolektif
düşünebilmesi Aslında birazcık borçluyuz
21 yüzyılda insan toplumlarının ve
dünyanın bekası için sorunlara ve
çözümlere eş Anlı olarak multidisipliner
yaklaşmak gerekiyor Buna ek olarak
farklı bakış açıları farklı
yetkinliklerin karar ve yönetim
süreçlerinde değerlendirilmesine ihtiyaç
var pandemi yaşanmasaydı bile dünyadaki
ekonomik sistemlerin devamı için de olsa
kadının karar süreçlerine ve masaya
davet edilmesi gerekiyordu niçin
dünyanın düzeltilmesi ve küresel
sistemin krizlerden çıkabilmesi için
farklı düşünce yapılarına farklı
kabiliyet ve tarzlara ihtiyacınız var
Yeni dönemde egoyu bir tarafa koyup
Kolektif
düşünebilmenin
gerekiyor karşılıklı diyaloğa
işbirliğine kadınların soft powera daha
çok yer açmalıyız kadın yönetici olarak
2001 2021 yılında göreve tekrar
başladığımda tedarik ve üretimden
başlayarak tüm süreçlerimizi ve
ürünlerimizi gözden geçirdik sağlığı
peynirimiz lezzetiyle buluşturmak için
antiinflamatuar özellikleri olan yeni
bir peynir çıkardık Türk kaşarını
üretmeye başladık
Zerdeçal ve
karabiberle zerdeçal doğada
antiinflamatuar yani iltihap çözücü
özelliği en yüksek olan bir Probiyotik
ve aynı zamanda probiyotikleri yaşatan
bir prebiyotik Biz zerdeçal karabiberli
Eee taze kaşarı çıkardığımızda sadece
Türkiye'nin değil dünyanın da Aslında
ilk zerdeçallı peynirini yapmış olduk
ardından
buna saç dökülmesine e herhangi bir Hani
ürün tanıtımı gibi olsun istemiyorum ama
yaratıcılık
açısından keza uzak doğuda zihin açıcı
olarak kullanılan Biberiyeyi dağ
kekiğini Karabiberi ekledik başa
dönersek her şerde vardır bir hayır
giden canlarımızı yerine koyamayız erken
gidenler canımızdan Can olanların
acısını bıraktığı boşluğu ancak
yaşayanlar bilir özlemlerimiz hayal
kırıklıklarımız bizi yine de kalanın en
iyi evr olması ve en iyi halimizi
gerçekleştirebilmek için alık koymamalı
Hayat dinamik ve Aslında konsantre
olduğumuzda o anda Eğer yığılmış İsak
yenilmişsem ihmal edebiliyor ya da tam
kullanamayız Oysa en büyük başarılar en
destansı zaferler en zor koşullarda
Çıkmamış mı Kurtuluş savaşımız gibi
resimdeki Benim dedem arkadaşlar
yardımcı olacaktır herhalde Pardon bu
değil Eee resimdeki e Benim dedem
Osmanlı ordusunda en az 12 yıl
yemen'de sonrasında Çanakkale'de
savaşmış sevgili atasıyla memleketini
savunmuş Dilek olay atamızın izninde ne
savaşlar kazanmış yokluklardan Ne Büyük
başarılar elde etmiş Şanlı bir neslin
memleketin çocukları torunlarıyız
küresel ekonomide karşımıza zaman zaman
çok zorluklar çıkıyor ama bunları
dönüştürebilmek mümkün gençlere
tavsiyem asla olmaz demeyin ve tüm
Zorluklara rağmen iyiliğin tecellisi
için gücünüzü küçümsemeyin daha iyi
hayal edin ve dirayetli olun her ne
yapacaksanız yapın Kolektif düşünmeyi
ihmal etmeyin bireysel olarak
gerçekleştiremediği Aslında Kolektif
akıl ve emekle
gerçekleştirebilir çok büyük başarılara
imza atabilirsiniz 6 Şubat 2023 günü
yoğun iş gündemi olan yeni bir haftanın
sabahı eşimden aldım acı haberi Maraş'ta
büyük bir deprem olmuştu felaketin
boyutunu bilememek le beraber bölge
insanı için çok
büyük felaketi en hızlı yardım
ulaştırabilen sivil bir inisiyatifi
kuracağım ilişkin en ufak bir fikrim
yoktu bazen Siz önceden hayal etmeseniz
bile Hayat size empoze eder işte o zaman
sizin gerçek kişiliğiniz değer
yargılarınız Gerçekte kim olduğunuz öne
çıkar iş hayatındaki İlk Yuvam Sermaye
Piyasası kurulundan meslektaşlarımızla
kurduğumuz gruba genç bir arkadaşımızın
Hatay'da 30 yakınının kaybettiğine
ilişkin bir mesajı
düştü ve ardından Geçmiş olsun taziye
mesajlarımız kendisinin ailesinden
bulunduğu yere ihtiyaçlarını gruba
yazmasını istedim birileri her halde
liderliği alır yardıma yardımlar
organize edilir Ben de zaten çok sıkışık
olan günlük rutinim dönerim ama ne yapar
ne eder katkıda bulunurum diye
düşünüyordum kriz yönetme tecrübesi
kazanmış bir iş insanı olarak çok hızlı
hareket edilmesi
gerektiğini düşünürken
saatler hızlıca geçerken ve peş peşe
artçılar yıkıma devam ederken
Eee ilk etapta gelen reaksiyonların
herhangi bir harekete geçişi
işaretlemedim fark ettim taziye ve
Geçmiş olsun mesajlarımız ötesine
geçemediğimiz görünce bölgedeki
depremzedelere yardım amacıyla ayrı bir
grup kurdum ve hızlıca destek
verebilecekleri çağırdım Emin ilk günü
kontrollü ve hızlıca kanalize olabilirim
diye kurduğum Grup bir gün içinde kapalı
olmasına rağmen 200 üyeye dayanmıştı
bile hızlıca Mersin'den satın al
yapılacak yola çıkarılacak şekilde ilk
yardım kamyonumuz lojistiğini olağanüstü
hal için izinlere organize ettiğimizde 7
Şubatı proforma satın alma işlemini
tamamlayıp kamyonu 3 saat sonra yani 2
gün içinde gün bitmeden hataya
ulaştırmayı hayal ederken aramızdan bir
bir arkadaş Eee yardım kamyonların
bölgeye alınmadığı ve benzeri sebeplerle
sevkiyattan Vazgeçelim dedi Oysa
hazırlıklarımız tamamdı Hatay'a
Mersin'den sevkiyat yapacaktık yasal
izinlerim de alınmıştı asgari
koşullarımız hazırken tereddütle geçen
her saat her Eee dakikanın maliyeti çok
büyüktü ikinci geceyi bölge bölgeye
gidecek ilk yardım olacağını yola
çıkmamız durumda Eee köydekiler eee
köydeki ölülerin vakaların sayısının
daha da artacağını izinlerim de olduğu
için Aslında çıkmamız bir sebebi
olmadığını kararlığı bozmamız
gerektiğini izah etmekle geçirdiğimi çok
iyi hatırlıyorum 3üncü günün sabahı
ertesi gün grupta yol açık yola çık
diyerek bireysel satın alma işlemini
Kolektif şekilde tamamlamaya ve
sevkiyatı yapmaya karar verdik
Mersin'den çıkan kamyonumuz Hatay deli
çay'a akşam saatlerinde ulaştı ardından
gönderdiğimiz ek yardımlarla Hatay deli
çay'a ilk 5 günde be ayrı sevkiyatı
başarıyla gerçekleştirmiş gıdadan hijyen
malzemesine ayakkabıdan battaniye Üstün
üst giyimden iç giyime çadıra ilaca
Hatta doktorlara bölgeye her türlü
yardım gidilmesini
sağlayabilmek Milyonlar mertebesinde
alımı koordineli yapmış sadece deli
çayın değil çevresindeki 10 köyün de
acil Hayati ihtiyaçlarını
karşılayabilmesi sayesinde gönüllü
Doktorlar da o bölgeye sevk olmuş ilk 56
günde 20 civarında açık ameliyat
gerçekleşmişti afet koşulları altında
ameliyatları yapan 11 köyde yaşayanların
sağlık kontrollerini gerçekleştiren tüm
sağlık görevlilerimize Ayrıca
minnettarız deliçay ve çevresine yardım
sevkiyatına ulaştırdığı kareleri ve
mutlu resimleri gördüğümüzde Son 5 günde
yardımları yetiştirebilmek için
dakikaları
kovalarına yaşadığımız stres ve yoğun
sorumluluk hissine karşın içimizin ve
gözlerimizin nasıl ısındığını size
anlatamam felaketin olmasını sade
vatandaş olarak engelleyemez deik ama
topyekün yaşanan trajedi karşısında
çöken ruhumuzu ayağa kaldırdığımız
yardım
götürebilmek yol açık olarak uzman
arkadaşlarımızın gönüllü çabalarıyla
üniversite öğrencilerin yurt içinde yurt
dışında burs kabul almalarına yardımcı
olduk sadece Hatay'da değil aynı zamanda
sonrasında Gaziantep Nurdağı Islahiye
arkada bazı görseller var diye biliyorum
Eee Islahiye Adıyaman Besni Eee ve daha
çok sayıda Maraş Elbistan Eee çok sayıda
Hatta e bölgeye yardımlarımız gitti
Arsus Samandağ ve Defne ağırlıklı olarak
da devam
etti çok sayıda çocuğa anneye teyzeye
amcaya süt veren büyükbaşa üreticiye
ulaşabildiğimiz için onların hayatta
kalma ve hayata tutunma mücadelesine
destek verebildiğimiz için yaşadığımız
yoğun duyguyu nasıl ifade etsem
bilemiyorum Tüm bunları 6 Şubat'ta ve
izleyen günlerde acımızı Kolektif olarak
bastırıp ayağa bildiğimiz için
gerçekleştirebildiği
çok sevgiyle karşılandı ve anıldı kısa
adıyla yaya Yeri geldi yaşanan acılara
pansuman Umut olabildi Bölge Jandarma
komutanlıklarına çok müteşekkiriz
Yolumuz hep açık
oldu aynı şekilde deprem Zed yardım
organizasyonlarımız için bize İtimat
edip destek veren tüm arkadaşlarım
gönüllü genç doktorlara olağanüstü
deprem ve kış koşullarına rağmen daha T
edemeden yardımlarımızı ulaştıran
şoförlere ayni destek Lojistik yardımı
yapan tüm kurum kuruluş İnsanlara çok
teşekkür ederiz tüm ülke olarak içimizi
parçalayan Asrın felaketi birbirini hiç
tanımayan insanlarımızı da bir araya
getirdi hep beraber iyileşmek için ayağa
kalktık çaba ve zamanla
iyileşeceğiz yol açık yol açık olarak
geniş satıhta travma yaşayan çocuklara
yetişkinlere sosyal ve psikolojik
desteğin yanı sıra sanatla mesleki
etkinliklerle doğayla yardımcı olmak
istiyoruz bunun için felaketin ilk
gününden beri hedeflediğimiz projemizi
genişlettik kurumsal kimlikle Hatay
Defne ve Samandağ'da Hayat yeniden çiçek
açıyor merkezimize ve merkezimizi ve ek
ünitesini kuracağız
kayıplarımızı en canları yılları yerine
koyamayız Ama yaraları sarmak pandemi ya
da iklim değişikliği gibi küresel
boyuttaki krizleri bile durdurabilmek
kolektif bir çabayla mümkün kötü
tecrübeyi iyiye değiştirmek mutluluğa
dönüştürmek mümkün iyi işler yapmaktan
size alıkoyan zaman zaman dikkatinizi
dağıtan negatif unsurlar süreçler
olabilir konuşmaların başında da
söylendiği gibi hiçbir yer Eee gül
bahçesi değil
benim gençlere tavsiyem iyilik düşün
hayallerini İnan umudunu Yenile
hareketin iyileştirici dönüştürücü
gücünden istifade et ayağa kalk bugün
burada bizi bir araya getiren ev
sahibimiz tedex Çanakkale organizasyon
komitesi'ni salondaki ve ekrandaki tüm
sevgili izleyicilere sevgi ve saygıyla
selamlıyorum yolunuz Yolumuz açık olsun